[Music]  [Music]  two canadian heart drops  one behind the scenes video after  dropping their collaboration monster  last week  shawn mendes and justin bieber gave  their fans an exclusive look at their  music video shoot  you put me on a paddy story  [Music]  to be honest between the small crew and  the eerie shooting location  it looks like the vibe on set was super  chill and can we just say that we're so  happy to see these two as friends and  collaborators  i'm sure that the beliebers and the  mendez army can also agree  that in a year as turbulent as 2020 we  were so glad to witness the positivity  that these two brought to set  i'm so blessed  [Music]  totally and also  [Music]  yeah i feel like there's a point where  you're like trying to rise  [Music]  i  listen to it